hello that rejects John here Greg here
we're gonna do a review of fantastic
beasts and where their Goblet of Fire
where did we we've never I don't think
we've stood together neither together
ever yeah this is weird
I never appeared on straight to the
point we do like movie trivia she bow
down and they have us to those interview
standing and stuff like yeah but now
there's some kind of like a little
strange
he's just sitting with you anyway right
we just cut back from watching fantastic
beasts and where where to begin with
this movie there's a cool film yeah I
thought it was cool I'll admit at first
like first 20-30 minutes I thought it
was like surprisingly slow but then it
started to feel like it's just taking
its time yeah yeah you know and if you
look at the last few Harry Potter films
they do take their time for the most
part especially the Deathly Hallows Part
1 and it's the same director and [ __ ] in
the same world so I shouldn't have been
totally thrown off like that it was like
whoa this is really slow you have a lot
of experience to draw from it yeah you
you know movies who are them then you
know all the books and stuffs like you
have enough experience to not know it
yeah gonna be I'm glad they made it like
a period piece that sort of had a chance
to own your whole like it took its time
it's so wet places but it took a little
more time than usual unfold is the key
word yeah the way it started off in the
first 20 minutes I felt totally
different about everything by the time
the movie ended actually yeah I was
really moved by the end I thought by the
end it was a really really damn good
movie well I thought at least you know
this might change cuz it's only a couple
hours after we saw it but I feel like
they did a nice job in broadening out
their world because yeah it felt
different for sure it felt like a
different city in a different time but
it still felt like it fit with the Harry
Potter yeah yeah you feel the universe
but it doesn't it definitely doesn't
feel like another Harry Potter movie or
a Harry Potter wannabe it's pretty dark
it it like it like the fur I know the
Harry Potter movies get darker as they
going not to make this whole review just
a comparison to Harry Potter there was
more human dark stuff in there
specifically like stuff with domestic
violence you can have like an orphan
type of neuron is your offer different
type of home what are those couples in
an orphanage the magic those children
which I mean is is a salient yeah
allegory like even though you don't
really see it but a lot of it like the
way it's done still is very
uncomfortable yes it still feels raw
well it's and again it's not too far
from you know things were still
struggling with in culture now yeah you
know the reason why I felt slow at first
is because this is an unfolding piece it
doesn't have like some prologue you know
title stroll beforehand or it doesn't
have like people making it very
expositional for you to really well you
have to pick it's one of those movies
where you don't have to pay like super
strong attention but you do have to pay
attention to pick up on who's who what
role they play who they are all that all
that stuff it's not told to you in an
expositional manner well yeah and I
think it was nice the JK Rowling got to
write the first sort of new format Harry
Potter material it's like she yeah she's
the credited writer I you know she wrote
this movie and I think that's a good
start because like the way it unfolds I
feel like is the way a movie authored by
her would it takes the time for its
character stuff it also shows you some
really dazzling magic for an original
screenplay it's pretty awesome for like
a Nega budget like original script it's
still very imaginative you still get to
see a lot of new kind of the wizarding
world like The Wizarding World here you
don't go to Hogwarts you know this this
world has consistently blended with the
human world really what they call no bag
no man no man no magic no magic no mad
magical yeah so they have the no magic
world
aka muggles so you're not just consumed
in Hogwarts for most of this or some
type of school this takes place in like
1920s New York yeah and that's really
cool like 1920s New York is awesome I've
been to New York a few times what I love
about New York just today is that the
buildings are still pretty much the same
it's it's you can feel you but you can
feel the history it feels more like a
polished up cleaner neater than what it
is now it's cool celebrities in that
time period in this it is cool because
you know I know the Harry Potter movies
are in America so to see the Wizarding
World in this in the States at a
different time to see reading not only
the Wizarding World in America you're
skating in a different time which was
really neat and you
but the magical world was like back then
how they're kind of like a secret
society in the ground yeah it's you know
it's it's not too hard for them to still
live underground
but yeah it's harder it's hard it's
harder they seem a lot darker I almost
felt like what I was watching a Harry
Potter x-men movie for some of them
because it is about like the magical
community and the humans like we have to
stay apart because humans flip out yeah
and get really violent and we can't keep
doing that and that's what I liked about
this movie too is that but the film was
filled with that but they touch on it
and a good amount of scenes we are
what's humans being aware that
witchcraft might be real that's right
later to this this whole franchise that
are doing that oh yeah and that's that's
what keeps all the action you know tense
still you do get some you know
fantastical action sequences with really
cool creatures and stuff but you always
have that worry in the background of
like this is not gonna be easy to get up
and this is going to really screw up
their society the stakes feel high Eddie
Redmayne is Newt Scamander I felt like
oh is this the role where heady red
mange is gonna be a cool like a cool
British dude like it's not gonna go on
character on us but that he did he's
like slightly old man yeah yeah he has a
very specific body language a bit like
he's constantly like this you know he
has a very specific body language a very
specific way of how he speaks - I really
enjoyed his performance even knowing him
isn't an unfolding experience they don't
really go out of their way to make him
like the most awesome dude or something
like right away like in terms of his
personality he's kind of quiet for a lot
of the film yeah it's kind of an odd guy
Harry Potter you have so many
wonderfully odd characters people really
like different characters and stuff so
if they took the time to make a new
totally new got a lead
cuz Harry Potter everyone's like hurry
Harry Harry Potter is freaking out Terry
bohner yeah and this character he's a
wizard alone in America you know like
yes there's a wizards in America but
British wizard in America is not a
common thing out there and the laws are
Divya totally you know the coefficient
of water in some ways in a lot of ways
actually he's a fish out of water so
seeing his adventure and fold and then I
didn't know the full story as to what
this movie was gonna be about and it
realizes briefcase contain like the
beasts and [ __ ] because I saw several
trailers and I didn't pick up on that I
don't want to like dive too much
that stuff the briefcase became cooler
and cooler as the movie progressed oh
yeah it became a lot cooler it wasn't
just like just a few cool things you can
do like there's some nice hidden gems in
there that that really made it like a
hoarder an awesome experience like
carrying around a little world with you
that's all I'll say yeah yeah like
carrying around a little who's imagining
where you go yeah and I like the way the
magic was approached in this it did feel
kind of like an alien world no it didn't
feel like a science fiction movie still
felt like a fantasy but you know kind of
makes me think of men and black in some
way
well yeah cuz it felt like there was
still in a real version of the world
people used magic the way you would if
you were trying not to be conspicuous
and like you had these things to worry
about you know it's not like oh cool
magic [ __ ] constantly but when it comes
in and a lot of Harry Potter is them
learning how to use magic and we we've
grown past that now so we get this new
character he knows a [ __ ] on a magic
already
he knows his shits on his spells and a
lot of that's really cool a lot of the
adventure he goes on that the surprise
character for me was Dan Fogelman and
yeah Wolski he's the human character in
the film who who just has that like
interesting luck of getting strung up in
this situation I'm gonna give it away
like when or what it is but yeah the
scene made me cry yeah it's manically
with him and he had a scene that we
laughed at for like 30 B yeah like just
one little moment but he's yeah he's a
great touch to the film because yeah
it's the first time you get a feel a
human being introduced into the
Wizarding World yeah yeah and like he is
a really sweet sort of fleshed character
it's nice to be reminded of how much I
enjoy
Dan Fogelman because he's really natural
and like he's naturally funny but he's
also very human just talking some bad
movies and yeah I feel like he's I
always thought I was like he's good he's
hasn't been in movies that really a lot
him is truly like showcase that he's
what something why he got he's super
sincere
crazy that you got to be in a movie like
this he's perfectly cast and I thought
you had an exceptional job a really
really good job yeah he's really sincere
and I really enjoyed what his character
brought to the movie and and you know he
brought that perspective and he
sympathize and empathy
for the guy oh my god and you identify
with him but he doesn't do it in like a
this easily could have been like one of
those roles where you just pity him and
that's why you care about him yet he
does it in a way where he doesn't feel
like he's self-pity well that's also
what makes the story so effective
because you know he's a nomad and
they're wizards in like in this society
they're not supposed to consort with
each other part of the journey of the
movie is him being like no this is
actually really cool like I accept you
guys let's see let's let's all be
together and so there is sort of a unity
that encourages all the characters to
sort of be sincere and get together yeah
definitely and I so yeah it's like it's
not like oh he's just the punchline or
not you know I've really enjoyed the the
relationship that formed it seemed very
believable this year for two very
different characters like Newt and
Kowalski - like really work together and
become good and become good friends it
was that's time forgiven for me you know
what Tony Tony but like for Newton
Kowalski like a lot of the time when you
put like a buddy pairing like that in
the film it usually feels forced or like
very like scripted I think it was like
good luck Chuck where Dan Fogelman was
Dane Cook's best friend okay where I was
like I get it you're two very different
people and you guys are best buds but
there's no [ __ ] way you guys would
really be friends in real life
okay you guys seem like you're stuck
with each other in this movie I really
enjoyed the way the chemistry was done
between them yeah they were learning
about each other like everyone's
learning in the yeah which is cool it's
an onsen unfolding experience you got to
give it some time before you're like
really swept away yeah and the way those
characters learn to like each others
really sincere and believable yeah and
the movie doesn't is big enough to let
him actually get interested in this
grand extraordinary thing that's
happening to him instead of spending
wasting a lot of time making jokes about
like this is insane yeah I should yeah
they made him a character that you
really cared about it rooted for in that
yeah and they do at times he is
necessary because he he needs to show
New York to get to complete the job
without giving too much it was about
love Harry without love without give me
too much away there's essentially two
plots going on in this film there's like
this dark
magic thing they don't know what it is
there's a lot of tension and Sammy's
building something is like Alex everyone
someone just take some time to destroy a
little bit of New York is this
Grindelwald coming back who knows and
then and the other story is with Newt
where he has his luggage full of [ __ ]
ton of features they have awesome
creatures and then because of an
unfortunate incident he loses some in
the process so it's my I'm trying to get
it back so you get to go on that
adventure would like seeing who the
beasts honor the beasts were cool the
creatures were cool in the beginning I
would get a little pulled out when I was
aware of how CGI's some act yeah
especially when I think it's always been
especially when there wasn't creatures
but they just had like animals at times
like when I had that lion show up on a
real line with that monkey yeah it was
like this doesn't look like a real
animal yeah it's too impressive like no
yeah I'm wrong it's like the effects are
so good I could just tell me but they
had a variety of creatures that were
like a variation of a specific type of
animal which I really like to like you
got your your Rhino type you got your
tiger like you got you got a bunch of
different kinds of animals in there and
creatures that really they were really
cool and that's another you know thing
that's kind of been throughout the books
and throughout the Harry Potter world is
like you know these sort of mythology
type creatures yeah you know they're
kind of reminiscent of you know Greek or
or Roman you know creatures and stuff
but it was cool to see them Toby have
that be one of its center focuses yeah
was the creatures that was that was a
great part of the film oh it's the
Avenger of going after finding these
creatures and then the other store so
yeah they're eventually just gonna come
together like you see that somehow
that's gonna happen everything adds to
the story yeah everything eventually
comes together Colin Farrell's in the
film plays graves I gotta say that Colin
Farrell he's always been able to do the
Muslim like painting like here's Irish
accent he has very specific Irish accent
yeah it's really thick he talks fast I
mean it does an American accidents like
damage just don't sound Irish it is
really like we all know you're Irish at
this point I'm not gonna say if he turns
out good or bad in the end what the
movie does a good job at doing is
sometimes making you think he's bad
sometimes making you think he's good
yeah like it does a good job at that and
they have one of the you know like
agents this with me I kind of thought
like man in black like especially when I
can raise humans minds and [ __ ]
yeah that's that Tina in there who is
like a wizard
agent inspector like yes she's she's
like she works for the Ministry of Magic
and America she was a cool character you
know a lot of these a lot of characters
you get in here like people who are
underdogs she's an ex-cop who has been
reassigned of a desk job but just for
magic yeah exactly yeah she's like an
XOR who's now doing like wand
registrations or something hi I thought
she did a really really good job too yes
like her chemistry with Eddie Redmayne
was really well done it starts off with
her character but it goes in an obvious
direction of like oh she's you know anti
Eddie Redmayne at first yeah and and of
course you know they're gonna become
friends or something like that when it
gets to that point I like how it was
done in organic way in the situations
that got into of how it felt natural
that they chose yeah it was you know
everything everything like that comes
together really natural and Tina's
sister who was she Queeny Queeny Oh
lizard who can read minds she was a neat
character you know cuz I pretty
enchanting yeah she was the character
that really was out of the 1920s which I
really appreciated seeing how likes
that's one thing that made the film fun
was there are very specific wizards and
human characters that are very much
tailored to the 1920s
oh yeah there's like a scene in a jazz
club with like a torch so yeah who
wasn't yeah I thought this guy was wrong
Perlman I gotta find out that was run
from yeah it was I saw the credits yeah
all right totally I call it right away
did it look like I'm off from alright I
heard that voice I was like Gabby romper
oh yeah the flash is in this film yes
you're Confucius Crespi credence like
Creedence Clearwater Revival yes yeah
they cut to like this story of that this
credence like these orphans with their
abusive orphan mom she's like this woman
who adopts
orphans but makes it known they're
[ __ ] orphans this movie kind of kicks
off all of its stories at one point
there's moment at the beginning where
they all meet on like the Town Hall
steps or whatever and there's a crowd
yeah
thank or something but that's when we
see a few key characters who eventually
will all feed the plot but we kind of
spiral off on them so yeah there is a
subplot about this like church orphanage
thing yeah run by this woman who's on it
anti witch and wizard crusade yeah some
people think they're freaks yeah yeah
there's one of their crazy bigotry so it
cuts back and forth to that and then
sorry really can't dive into anything so
now boiler b-major spoilery to give
anything away about cuz their answer
miller is playing at all in this phone
as it reveals a lot not just for ezra
Miller's character but for other
characters too I get spoils a lot
well yeah you see the trailer and you
see the adventure stuff but like there's
more in this movie than I was expecting
yeah there's a lot there's a lot more
significant plots of the heavies seem
like they advertised we're being careful
there's also a lot of creatures of magic
that you probably only got a minor
glimpse of in the trailer
yeah and spend a lot of time with the
creatures which I could which I thought
was great one thing that I appreciate
about this film was that it felt like a
complete movie it did and that was the
concern I had going into it didn't I
love Harry Potter I grew up with a
Potter and I was like we're starting a
new franchise I'm worried and like the
way that the Lord of the Rings movies in
Lord of the Rings felt and the way how
Harry Potter films felt was they all
felt like complete films Harry Potter
you needed sequels to finish that story
fantastic beasts oh I'm doing I still
feel fantastic beasts ends in a way work
yeah we could use sequels to see more of
what's going on but I still like that it
felt like a complete film yeah and here
if it wanted to but it could also
continue if it wanted to it didn't feel
like one of those franchise first
installment films and that was what I
didn't want you know cuz because we're
diving into uncharted territory even the
book that this is based on is like an
encyclopedia is the book he's writing in
the moon I was worried because this is
new territory and I'm always like we're
gonna create [ __ ] just for the movie
yeah so I wanted to be good and and this
was a nice vote of confidence for that
because it seemed like it was interested
in telling a story and it was interested
in telling you know and digging into it
and doing more than just giving you cool
[ __ ] like The Hobbit like you know it
wasn't a hobbit situation and I was
afraid it could be one thing I will say
though that I thought was see this
either like they're either do
some franchising [ __ ] here or JK rowling
probably had a much larger script I
imagine she would as a novelist whose
books get exceedingly longer you know
like I imagine if she had a longer
script they probably had to trim down a
lot of [ __ ] probably look there's this
one storyline with involving Jon
Voight's character and I'm pointing out
because he's in the trailer that just
felt like not necessary in this film it
didn't feel like it really tied up at
all it felt a little bit like there was
probably more they cut out of that or
they're trying to you know set up or
something in a sequel I feel yeah it
felt like he had a plot that they went
somewhere else or you know got cut down
for time or something it becomes like
you have this you know veteran actor in
a role that kind of satisfies what's
going on in the background the actions
he takes are never a direct threat to
the plot it's just sort of he represents
what's bad about the status quo doesn't
really seem to have any real effect on
anything else outside of that's there's
there's like three scenes yeah you're a
human like thank you for getting Johnny
wait but didn't anybody but like I said
it's only like three scene II like three
scenes with that so it's not a lot of
the film it does take time and those
three scenes to cut away from everything
and focus on it yeah it's still
interesting like it still adds something
for me to the story because at least you
check in with like oh here's what's
going on more in the nomad world you
know the muggle world and that's
something I'm interested in as long as
we're spending time in addressing you
know we're taking enough time to keep
the audience aware of the tension
between non magical and magical people
like it was nice to check in with that
plot and be like oh here's one magic
people are doing this it does add in but
sense because they are up higher they're
a high authority in the human world to
the point that when you know Wizarding
[ __ ] starts going wrong and then they
start to notice yes add to the intensity
it might even just be wrapped up in this
one story on it's like yeah it just
doesn't feel pertinent that we check in
yeah yeah that's a good that's the best
way to put it but overall yeah I mean it
first moves slow but then I realize you
know it's just taking its time and I
like that because in a film with this
big of a budget a lot of these effects
you usually feel like they move really
fast and it was cool to see that right
from the beginning they turn everything
into
scenes that they allowed to play out
yeah which I appreciated I feel like a
lot of time we get rushed projects so to
see if film from Warner Brothers
especially Blair well they've done JK
Rowling nothing yeah if she's pretty
yeah he seems like she has a pretty good
judgment she yeah this movie has that
great blend of knowing when to like
focus on like new kind of awesome Wizard
World stuff and then coke go with the
plot moving forward yeah just focus on
character it's a good play it's a really
well crafted film like I said this was
sort of a vote of confidence to me of
like this is what you want your new
franchise to feel like and I'm on board
for it JK Rowling seems to know what
she's you know what should do I'm
excited now I've not as into it as I was
when I saw the first Harry Potter film
but I mean I felt good enough about it
where but I feel like if they take like
too long on a cibano sequels already
like being filmed or some [ __ ] this is
one of those franchises around like if
you take more than like three years off
I might not be interested in your sequel
to be honest I might forget about like a
lot of this stuff that happens I'm
interested in the kind of stories this
seems like it's gonna tell like then
take that back that you know what I like
where this movie's going I think I have
to say that to get that on my mind but
now that I said it I really think I
should be a really cool story is it
moves differently and it's a different
kind of movie than Harry Potter which i
think is good as much as we've made
comparisons to Harry Potter this film
like doesn't which I really like you
know it's not like watching a Marvel
movie or a common thing these days where
it's there's like tons and tons of
references to like what's going on
because even though it's a different
time period technically in the past
before Harry was even born it's still
only like acknowledges Hogwarts
you know acknowledges Dumbledore that's
about as far as it really go because it
has a roof going this toys in there it
doesn't but it doesn't even do yeah it
doesn't feel like they're trying to go
this doesn't see it's done in a really
subtle way work it does feel like a
different world in the same universe
yeah and we've spent so many movies with
those same characters and we know yeah
we know the scope of the world it felt
natural to me when I was watching now
they gotta go
China or as your new president says
China it's still in the same universe
but not in a way that feels you know
pantry like you said and I think like
that's what's nice about this movie is
is it takes the time to be its own type
of movie yeah you know it's it's not the
same kind of movie as Harry Potter and
they're not the same and when the
characters too I got like super cool II
did it that way because it do the
characters in a way we're not like okay
that's the Harry Potter archetype that's
the Hermione art type just watching
different people oh you know yeah
totally they fought through it yeah and
they really bothered to bring a very
human story to everything while still
giving you the magic and the excitement
to you know this is surprisingly dark
but not in a way that's dour
okay we got serious for a minute but
there's also a lot of fun
does make you want to have a wand again
yeah good vibes man it does make you
want to have a wand it does it does make
you want it just makes you want to live
in a magical world because like just
looks like so much easier the way they
do construction and put everything back
together
well that but even even when they're
just like there's a little scene where
they're all just having dinner together
and you're like life just seems like it
would be a little bit nice it was just
like a plate floating in the bed that's
cool it still is transported well rating
system time you know why it's pretty
good I would say it's a lot fantastic I
liked it a lot I thought it was pretty
good pretty good not one of the ratings
it's not oh yeah it's either good great
fantastic or amazing masterpiece I would
say this is fantastic
oh they paid you and it did Warner
Brothers pays me for everything that
promote yeah everybody knew the channel
you can subscribe a day become a reject
Jon's reasons Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram you could follow facebook.com
slash the real rejects and bloom house
take care mr. Trump take care China